what does this mean practically in terms
of the map
well
larry sabato who is again
a left-leaning guy who runs the center
for politics at the university of
virginia
he has something called the crystal ball
the crystal ball is is ratings for
particular senate races and right now
he has just moved a bunch of races away
from the democrats so arizona georgia
and nevada were lean d
yeah i always thought by the way that
that was a bit of an overstatement they
are now considered toss-ups by larry
sabato
colorado which was a safe democratic
seat is now being shifted to a likely
democratic seat
okay so if you look at the map right now
that means that lean republican seats
include wisconsin which remains a alien
republican seat
in ohio which remains a likely
republican seat unclear who's going to
emerge from that ohio primary whether
it's jd vance or whether it's josh
mandel it'll be interesting to see
because both of them are very trumpy
in the toss-ups according to larry
sabato and the center for politics over
at the university of virginia
pennsylvania georgia arizona nevada
republicans only need to pick up two of
those in order for them to win control
of the senate
nevada looks pretty good for them nevada
is is a is an ugly scene right now for
the democrats georgia i think
republicans just win back i think
republicans win back georgia i think it
was a fluke that they lost the last time
i think it was largely driven by the
fact that donald trump decided in the
final days of the campaign that he was
going to tell republicans not to vote
because of
charges of voter fraud or some such
other silliness
the reason i call that silliness is
because whatever you think of voter
fraud not voting is a really really dumb
and stupid solution to that considering
you handed two seats to the democrats in
georgia which is in fact a red state
okay arizona it is not kristin cinema
who's up in arizona it's mark kelly
who's up in arizona but that state seems
to be trending red again because of the
nature of the the political moment
pennsylvania is a harder state for
republicans but a bunch of pennsylvania
appellate court judges were just elected
as republicans so if there is low
turnout in some of the big cities and
democrats do not duplicate what they did
in 2020 in pennsylvania that could go
republican too so if all shifted to the
republicans you'd be looking at 53 seats
for the republicans in the senate
remember all they need to do is pick up
two
they just need to hold in wisconsin and
they need to pick up two more seats
that's it and if they do that they win
the senate so this is now i would say a
likely republican senate map and
democrats are looking at that and they
realize that they are likely to lose
both houses of congress in the next
election cycle
okay it's a disaster for them and so
once again they are presented with some
choices
the choices for the democrats are
you can follow the moderates
you can follow the progressives or you
can follow the crazies now i know that
everybody in politics right now is
separating the the democrats into two
categories rather than three right
they're saying they're the moderates and
they're the progressives and among the
moderates they're counting people like
nancy pelosi and chuck schumer and joe
biden this is incorrect
right now the democratic party is
divided in three ways it's divided
between the crazies that would be on the
spending side carmilla giant paul from
washington on the on the overall side
that would be the squad
the moderates this would be in the house
people like abigail spanberger from
virginia
and in the senate it would be mansion
and cinema
and then you have the progressives the
progressives are actually biden and
pelosi and schumer
the democrats right now are heavily
loaded toward the progressive side
they could stop this right they could do
what bill clinton did after he got blown
out in 1994 he lowered capital gains
taxes he signed on to welfare reform he
started working with the republicans on
the other side of the aisle to come up
with some sort of moderate policy
do you think the democrats are really
going to do that or are the democrats
going to keep doubling down on stupid
it's fascinating to see how this breaks
out
down media and across the democratic
side of the aisle because this is a real
open argument in the media and on the
democratic side of the aisle i think
it's kind of hilarious that every time
democrats lose an election they have
this brief moment this just brief moment
particularly the media they have a brief
moment where they're like
what if we talked to people what if we
got out of this little bubble that we
live in here on twitter and we actually
went and talked to people who don't
think like us and we tried to comprehend
what they were saying jim acosta had
this brief moment of clarity yesterday
on cnn it was quite amusing
if you look at what happened in those
red counties those bright red counties
from the shenandoah valley all the way
down to southwestern virginia that is
trump country uh and democrats have not
been able to make inroads in that part
of virginia and those kinds of rural
areas around the united states for a
very long time now and i suspect that
democrats may need to do a little less
lecturing and more listening when it
comes to those rural voters to help them
get back
into the good graces of those kinds of
americans
now i always laugh when i hear this sort
of stuff from the media because they
spent four years doing precisely the
opposite right after trump won
there's this brief moment in time where
democrats like maybe we should read
hillbilly elegy maybe we should actually
send selena zito out to talk to these
these trump voters as though she was
like jeff corwin going into the wild or
something they'd wear like australian
hats they who are these trumposes what
are they doing how do they think
and then after five minutes they're like
nah they're all racist we're not gonna
pay any attention to them anymore
probably it was facebook probably it was
the russians they have this brief moment
of clarity and in that brief moment of
clarity lies the possibility for
democratic hope
they're probably not going to take it i
mean there are other commentators who
are providing sort of this moment of
clarity as well for example there's a
one former obama advisor stephanie
cutter and she says you know what we're
really scared of is that the republic
republicans are going to become the
party of parents right we tend to break
americans down by demographic group by
racial group by age group but there is
one group of people who actually are
united by interest that pretty much
nobody has taken advantage of yet and
that of course are parents right once
you have kids your interests change
there's a reason that married women with
kids vote very differently than single
women here's stephanie cutter
recognizing that reality
the one thing that we need to make sure
that uh republicans in 2022 don't become
is the party of parents
because we need to be the party
and and we are we're the ones that care
about school funding we're the ones that
care about making sure that parents can
send their kids to school uh because
they have jobs to go to you know all of
this we need to own that agenda we
cannot let it go and it's not just about
critical race theory it's a it's coming
out of covet it's parental frustration
as parents being involved in their kids
schooling we need to pay attention to
all of it
okay she's right about this democrats
have no capacity to shift they have no
capacity to shift on this they're
unhawked the american federation of
teachers which fought hard against kids
going back to school they believe that
the american federation of teachers
should be able to determine solely how
your kids are taught
it's very hard to make the case that
you're the party of parents when you're
also the party of abortion that's a very
difficult argument to make just
philosophically speaking
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang